that's true just be [ __ ] making like
commentary that everybody disagrees with
no actually fighting a live stream
fighting like me fighting some buyer did
I would totally I would pay for that
I'll subscribe to you you were the crazy
like a subscription I I like I enjoy
fighting a lot right like smart I spar
consistently yeah
the only problem is is that with with
fighting that the biggest difference is
is that you can't play fighting yeah I
mean my room when you're in it you're in
it yeah so and I'm a very obsessive
person like when I did the film I
dropped everything mm-hmm and I only did
that film for like seven eight months
yes all I did yeah
and you know it did really well but I'd
become very obsessed with something
because I hate putting like half my foot
in and not really committing you're like
a 200% guy exactly because it was suck
for me to try something only once and
then know that I could have done more
you know because even if that film that
I did didn't go into Sundance or
whatever I would have been I was very
happy with it it's like I think this is
a great film so I could walk away from
it and be happy yeah and even when I do
that people are like well what's your
next thing that you want to do and I'm
like I don't know if I have a next thing
I never said I wanted to be an actor I
never said I wanted to be this and that
it was an opportunity that came up it
was something that I wanted to prove to
myself and then prove to other people
and it worked out yeah so with fighting
I would drop everything this podcast
would disappear and I would be signing
up for multiple multi geum's and minions
and grappling gyms and I'll be doing
that six seven days a week for like two
years straight mm-hmm and then I go into
my first match so it's like do I really
want to do that I think I'm a little too
old now I'm not too old but it's like I
wash the face yeah I got I got a black
eyes like a couple weeks ago - I was
like look at this thing dude doesn't
[ __ ] go away I can't tell it's like
it's like oh I see it no it's kind of
there but people always ask like what
the [ __ ] happened what the yeah yeah in
the face I just chipped Yoshi's tooth
today Oh serious sparring which I felt
sure which tooth well he has veneers in
the Front's of their fake oh so you can
just get it filled up yeah so he got it
he got a fix today I was like huh I felt
terrible cuz he has a commercial shoot
tomorrow good thing it's not a real
tooth though I it would have [ __ ] I
wouldn't hurt my man keep your chin down
close your [ __ ] mouth when you get
stuck in the face dude he wasn't wearing
a mouth guard he was in the match
the sparring round before mm-hmm but
then they was hurting his gum so he took
it out and right one round that he
thinks about I saw him in the face and
it judging who is there anyone you would
fight in the youtube world that you
think would be a good match for you I
mean you a you would anyway like 1 2 to
17 right now ok yeah I'm to 7 so you'd
be like a heavyweight yeah I would drop
down to like 170 though yeah that's like
30 pounds 40 pounds yeah I could do it
anyway it's not about 170 I'd still be
pretty healthy at this height like 175
mm-hmm I would probably um if I'm not
cutting weight I'll probably fluff up to
about 185 mm but 175 I could do it is
there anyone who would you fight in the
YouTube world I don't know man I mean
people were like they see like these
videos and they go box Logan Paul look
at Paul's not a bad boxer guys he would
[ __ ] me up he's pretty good he's an
athlete natural athlete yeah look at him
too he's jacked yeah he looked a little
red too I must say he did a little but
he might have [ __ ] you know I mean like
all those guys would [ __ ] me up they
have the best boxing trainers training'
them they have unlimited money and an
unlimited time what if you did what if I
did yeah you had those trainers I don't
know we would see like I think like I
wouldn't mind taking a boxing match from
anybody if I had the right time all
right let's take away Logan Paul who
teeth who would you fight I don't know
anybody it would literally be anybody as
long as they were in the same weight
class you fight uh right scum he's like
I don't know I actually don't know what
his body stats I know what his face
looks like and it's what his voice
sounds like but I don't know what his
body looks like
I think he's tall like I think he's like
6 feet tall oh really I think is he like
Jack I've I don't think I've met him in
person yeah but I heard he's like tall
oh yeah that fight him he looks like he
has a fun date as [ __ ] lame I find
right now let's make it happen I don't
really know you might be a really nice
kid to like yeah Oh would you feel bad
if you like beat up a nice kid yeah like
I want somebody to give me a fighting
chance but I'm gonna talk [ __ ] about you
and then give you a reason to be like
i'ma beat your ass probably but like I'm
at you what the funny thing is like I
realized this about myself too now maker
I just don't care anymore I can't get
angry enough to hit somebody yeah like
let's say that rice come get here
he goes oh you think you could beat me
up and he makes a rap battle dis about
me hahahaha
alright bro I think you know like I'm
probably still not gonna fight you
yeah I was like if you if you want real
beef then I'm not a thug or anything but
if you want to [ __ ] me up just let's
meet up at a spot let's throwdown
if I get [ __ ] up I get [ __ ] up it is
what it is what if there's money on the
line money yeah I would fight Logan Paul
for the amount of money that they may
have don't get my ass like dude David
you got beat yeah I got ten million
dollars I don't give a [ __ ]
I suck a dick for a lot less dude what
are you talking about David that's
different dude of course you know if it
was like you know fight right how much
okay let's say Logan Paul you get your
ass beat you're bloody you won't lose a
tooth because you're wearing a mouth
guard but you'll get some black guys
bloody nose maybe it's can you spray in
the nose you could break your nose break
your nose okay let's say you break your
nose would you do it for like 200 grand
do it now a little higher than that 300
grand it would have to be at least a
million half a million - just like Oh
half a million cash that's basically a
million yeah half a million cash [ __ ]
yeah half a million wired to you a check
okay yeah let's do it if look at publish
like David so I'm gonna [ __ ] you up in
front of live television for a half a
million dollars
I wouldn't even throw a punch I would
let him knock me out in the first row
for four hundred thousand why do you
keep going low or a hundred thousand
four hundred thousand has to do it three
hundred thousand now 350 come on no I
need that four hundred thousand that's a
lot for two thousand with the money that
I have now Michael you have to put on a
fight though you I I honestly feel like
if you're in that ring you would not you
would not just sit there and let him
beat your ass I think you would actually
fight I would also take a nice cocktail
steroids but dude what if you won that
would be amazing though yeah that'd be
great for my I'd be very proud actually
I'll be proud of myself especially cuz
he's been training for two years
straight yeah with the with in the best
boxing trainer and [ __ ] physical
trainers in the world yeah and if
somebody like me who's just on my dime
just gets you know training from
somebody and I beat him then that just
means he sucks it's like that means you
really suck if you lose him that's true
right no no no it might mean that you're
just that
I'll please it I that good I've been
doing this [ __ ] for like a year and a
half got any better I'm not scared to
like throw down yeah if I have to but
it's like I don't have that that youth
rage anymore yeah no one you're I know
what you mean yeah yeah I mean like when
we were young we would get mad yeah but
I don't get mad like that either
yeah yeah I get irritated yeah like the
only person that pisses me off is my
fiance that's it yeah I can't punch her
you can't no that's like she could punch
you though oh for sure she makes me boil
Emad but anybody else it's like [ __ ] you
guy yeah I just move on as a waste of
time yeah it's a complete waste of time
and I'm kind of glad that I got to that
point cuz when I was younger I couldn't
fight for [ __ ] but I would just start
swingin I'm like less you see what
happens
yeah I don't know why when you're
younger you're so confident that you
would kill everybody yeah it doesn't
make any sense yeah it's like it's like
you're thinking in your head I could do
this and then I'll do that and it'll be
on the floor well I saw you get mad once
on Cato like I did
[ __ ] mad in k-town many times [ __ ]